you can hear you okay um so I have
recently um accepted Christ I've been a
Muslim before um You can call me no um
and uh I've been having troubles with my
parents I've been talking to them and
they have a lot of questions which I'm
trying to help uh answer um it will be
really helpful if you could answer some
of those questions for my mother um
course so one of the questions she had
was in the Bible she was she started
researching about the Bible um and one
of the questions she had was why did
Jesus say that father is greater than I
am something like that yeah um so how
does he say that father is greater than
him when he's also God right uh could
you explain on that yeah okay thank you
so first of all sister I want to say man
congratulations and God bless you for
coming out of that darkness and also
being a witness to your household your
family members so praise God we all
praise God for you um it's very brave
it's you know it takes courage to go
against the grain and accept Christ when
you know not as when everyone else
around you is against it so uh man God
bless you for your courage and your
strength and I pray that the holy spirit
continues to strengthen you and give you
wisdom and guidance on how to walk in
this faith and things of this nature so
but yes so the question is so the verse
that she's actually talking about my my
sister is John 14: 28 and so I I'll pull
up the verses here so that we can all
take a look at
it and see how to break this stuff down
in context Jesus says the father is
greater than I if he's God then how can
it be that the father is greater than
him right so let's uh let's break this
down here John chapter 14 one of my
favorite chapters in the entire Bible
and uh this is objection that we get
often really old and so but let's pull
this up I going to show you how Jesus is
talking in John 14 that leads up to
verse 28 what is he talking about okay
so let me go ahead and share this really
quick let me put my screen
up all right so let me zoom in so this
is the verse
here he said says you heard me say to
you I am going away and I will come to
you if you loved me you would have
rejoiced because I am going to the
father for the father is greater than I
uh oh Jesus can't be God if there's
somebody greater than him right no
that's not what this is so what what
what we have is is what in what sense is
Jesus talking about the father being
greater than him he uses this elsewhere
watch this he use in the same chapter is
what he says in verse 12 watch he says
truly truly I say to you whoever
believes in me will also do the works
that I do and greater Works than these
will he do because I am going to the
father uh oh wait Jesus you're saying
that Believers will be able to do better
things than you greater things than you
no that's not what he's saying
here greater when they he's talking
about they're able to do Greater Works
than him it's greater in quantity right
not greater in quality like they'll be
doing better Works than him they're
going to be doing the same works that he
did just at a greater scale because he's
leaving he won't be here to do these
works anymore so they're going to
surpass him in number in doing these
Works does that make
sense um so to sum it up um it was not
refer to Greater in sense of
position
but um could you explain on that yeah so
the yeah so I'm gonna get there in a
second I just wanted to show you how
there's a there's different senses in
which the term greater is used depends
on the context so like here example as
we're looking at we see greater in
number not greater in quality like
they're going to be doing better Works
than him just greater in number because
he's leaving he's going away so now when
we get to Jesus again where he says that
the father is greater than I what does
that mean well it means that the father
is greater than him in yes position in
Authority not greater in nature or you
know in his Essence because they have
the same Essence but Jesus humbled
himself and took the form of a servant
that's why the father in that sense is
greater than Jesus because he submits to
the father he humbles himself before for
the father so it's greater in position
not greater in essence or nature so does
that does that mean that when Jesus
Christ was in a human form he uh because
he was limited to the human body he was
not as great but after his resurrection
he became at the same level of greatness
with God and he's the
god well actually this is a this is
something is interesting this is
something that Jesus gives up as far as
when it comes this is one of the things
that he sacrificed when he came in the
flesh he set aside those type of that
type of that position where he's not
submitted or under the father in that
sense but that you know he's you know at
the same level got that same Authority
and stuff like that but Jesus gave that
up and set that aside when he humbled
himself and took on flesh so let me show
you this because this verse actually
down very beautifully it's in um it's in
Philippians chapter two Paul breaks this
down excellently in Philippians
chapter thank you yeah of course of
course it's a good question usually you
know they bring this up it's it's really
it's a good question you can't you know
but the Bible has the answers for
that you know so uh see what I'm
doing
all right so in Philippians chapter 2 is
talking about it's talking about the uh
the authority uh the humbleness of God
the humility that we are all supposed to
have the same humble mindset that even
Jesus had right so when we get to this
watch it says in verse five have this
attitude in
yourselves have this attitude in
yourselves which was also in Christ
Jesus who as he already existed in the
form of God right so he he was already
God he already had the form of God right
it says did not consider equality with
God something to be grasped or held on
to equality with the father he didn't
have to he didn't hold on to it he let
it go right but it says but but emptied
himself or another word says made made
himself of no reputation right by taking
form of a bonder servant and being born
in the likeness of men okay and verse
eight and being found in appearance as a
man he humbled himself by to the point
of death even death on a
cross
right okay yeah this is a this is a
difficult concept well I think
you know it is it I think it's a
difficult concept only if you don't let
the uh scriptures just kind of speak
right Avery can you drop pull my screen
up real quick because there's something
really interesting In this passage I'm
gonna make this bigger so people can see
it but when you go to John 14:26 which
in is in the same vicinity I want us to
think about this Jesus is speaking in
the context of him being sent right of
the father being greater than him but
he's going to return in that sense but
look what he says about but the helper
the holy spirit so the holy spirit is
God also
it says the father will send it in Jesus
name hold on for a second why is the
father sending the Holy Spirit who is
God also in the name of the son if
there's not some sort of equality there
it's all about the order and then look
what it goes on to say in
1526 it says when the helper comes who I
will send to you from the father so
Jesus himself is sending the Holy Spirit
from the father and active in that whole
scenario so who can and the Hebrew Bible
tells us who can control the spirit of
God other than God himself so all we
have is just a role of equality and
unity within the tri Unity of God and so
people say oh now the Holy Spirit got
the short end of the stick right no no
no when we go to John chapter 3 it was
the Holy Spirit that descended upon the
Messiah and empowered him to go out into
the Wilderness and strengthen him
through his temptation and trials and
then came upon him after he defeated the
Enemy by resisting temptation so the
Holy Spirit was actually strengthened
the Messiah in his humanity and they
work together in this beautiful unity
and imp perfect love submitting to each
other in that sort of sense so father
son Holy Spirit totally God but in the
wider context Jesus is in control of the
spirit of God this makes him God right
um so so looking at all those verses
together is really
important okay um also one more thing
about this when you talked about the
Holy Spirit a lot of the Muslims we kind
of like we kind of believe that um after
Jesus Christ said after I leave he will
send the advocate the the spirit of
truth right and they refer that it was
he was referring to Muhammad um peace be
upon him that's what they refer and um
well the the thing is I have experienced
the holy spirit so I understand what
what you're talking about but my mother
does not like uh so I became Christian
on the birth of Jesus Christ during the
December like last December and um I was
praying to God to show me a sign um to
help me and I I I've you know some
Miracles happened and I felt the
presence of Jesus Christ or the holy
spirit so I know how it feels but how do
I explain this like the concept of H
like holy spirit coming in to you and
helping you and guiding you to the right
path like how do I explain this to
Muslims who just does not understand the
concept of the Holy
Spirit
Rabbi yeah I think that we don't faith
is a gift of the spirit of God and so
people have to turn to the Lord um
there's this interesting passage in in
one of the books of Corinthians where it
talks about that there's a veil over the
eyes of the Jewish people and really
what's veiled is the truth of the good
news of the Messiah and the Torah is
veiled and they really can't see the
Messiah but it's an interesting thing
that Paul says there he says when a
person turns to the Lord then their Veil
is removed and they can see the Messiah
in the scriptures and see the gospel and
the good news so there is no what we do
here we don't argue people into Faith
right right what we do is we we show
inconsistencies in worldviews that are
not the biblical worldview and what that
does is that should make people feel a
little bit off balance and have trouble
walking we we put a pebble in the shoe
by the help of the Holy Spirit and then
when people are walking with this Pebble
in their shoe and they turn to they say
Lord show me what's going on which is
the very thing that you did in your
testimony you said Lord show me Give Me
A Sign reveal it to me and that's when
it's going to happen so for you what I
would recommend is watch these streams
learn this material so that you can show
that Islam is inconsistent and that the
Quran cannot be the word of God because
of its inconsistency and false claims
and contradiction with the Bible amongst
many other things that the amazing
Brothers on here do so I would say to
pray for an opening up of the eyes of
your mother and others to see this thing
and to learn the argumentation and that
the Holy Spirit would extend the spirit
of Grace to your mother and other family
members to come to the Lord and you can
show how the Bible is actually
consistent and true historically
linguistically and all of that from
beginning to end there's fulfilled
prophecies the Quran doesn't have any of
those so when you show these things it's
not going to be you con vincing them but
God himself is going to move with your
words as people turn and then they're
going to say Lord what's right God show
me if Jesus is the Messiah show me
something to that effect and God's going
to reveal himself and that's what it's
about right but um the problem I'm
facing is that people are kind of
blinded even though they are lot you
know they have the common sense uh but
they you know they do daily stuff but
they would uh block themsel you know my
elder brother he
he just graduated and you know I I
considered him to be like more most
mature of our family he would understand
what I'm talking about uh but I even
after being so educated he was like oh I
don't you know uh I I'll be blind he com
he completely said I will just follow
what I've been learning for last um many
years and what my granddad did and I
will not listen to anything else you
know and this is what has been always
happening around me that uh whenever I
talk to my siblings my parents they
would say that this is all that has been
happening in our culture in our
traditions for the last many years so
why would we even think of something
else right um and they even after being
having logical um you know brain they
would just block themsel from listening
yeah right it's just it's just difficult
and they consider me to be someone who
got brainwashed or something the ner the
nerve it's it's so interesting what
you're saying uh thisat it's it's it's
crazy because um that you're you're I I
say this all the time when I talk to
these people um it's not just Muslims
but just non-believers period uh
atheists uh you know other other you
know jehos winess it doesn't matter
talking to these people showing them
these things and you know all of it
makes sense none of these people I don't
believe like some people will be like
man he man this guy's dumb or that guy's
an idiot and I'm like no no he's not
he's not dumb he's he's not he's just
spiritually Dead He's spiritually blind
you know I don't I truly don't believe
that these now there's levels to it now
there might be somewhere okay this man
that he's just he's just out of his mind
but for the most part I do not believe
that these that these people that I talk
to are are dumb people I do not think
that um and I just want to share this
really quick like with Paul it literally
is like this what what needs to take
place in at Paul's conversion it says
here um in verse 17 um after the Lord
called him said so ananas departed and
entered the house and after laying his
hands on him said brother Saul the Lord
Jesus who appeared to me uh I'm sorry to
who appeared to you you on the road by
which you were coming has sent me so
that you may regain your sight and be
filled with the Holy Spirit and
immediately something like fish scales
fell from his eyes and he regained his
sight and he got B he got up and was
baptized took food and was strengthened
so it says that something like scales
fell from Paul's eyes at his conversion
when he when the the Holy Spirit entered
him and he was filled with the Holy
Spirit scales fell from his eyes it
wasn't Paul was very educated right
Rabbi Paul was educated in the law he
was educated in the scriptures he was a
Roman citizen he was he he he knew what
he was talking about he he he knows how
to debate he wasn't a dumb dude but he
was spiritually blinded and had scales
over his eyes that needed to come off
only by the power of the holy spirit so
that's what we're dealing with yeah let
me let me throw something at you that's
interesting if you could put back on my
screen brother I'm going to share
something about the uh the spirit of God
and just give you a little a little bit
of you know I don't think we're going to
rinic Jews but maybe we could share some
nuggets right acts 16 is a phenomenal
passage Paul is traveling and he's
trying to figure out which way to go
it's related to the Holy Spirit
discussion we're
having see we can we can talk about
whether people want to believe what the
Bible says right and why whether they
should or shouldn't there's plenty of
people who do that kind of apologetic
thing all the different argumentation
that's cool but there are are no
multiple interpretations of what it
actually is saying and declaring and the
Bible teaches that God is one being with
three persons and I just want to share
something with you and then I want to
Echo it with the rabbis look what this
says they were passing through these
different regions and they were
forbidden by the Holy Spirit to speak
the word in Asia right so after they
came to missia they were trying to go
into bethenia and look at who stops them
the spirit of
Jesus right the spirit of Jesus and the
Holy Spirit are being used
interchangeably as God moving throughout
the world right so it's really it's
really fascinating right that we're
saying and what are we saying here we're
saying the New Testament teaches that
the Holy Spirit speaks as God but also
not as the father or not as the spirit
but there is some overlap between them
and then I want to share this other
thing that even the rabbis believe this
right let me show you this this insane
thing this comes from a text of called
Tana Dei eliyahu this is a rabic
medieval work and look and so the rabbis
are commenting on some passages and you
know the background isn't as important
but it's something they interesting they
say about the Holy Spirit they look what
it says when the Lord's voice is heard
at the time of the messiah's coming the
whole world will be agitated saying is
it possible that God is coming to the
world to destroy then look at who's
going to talk the holy spirit will reply
saying the king of the king of Kings
Blessed Be he is coming only to join in
a feast with his children right so the
holy spirit being God even according to
the rabbi speaks in in a separation from
God but still being God himself right
and this lines up with the with the New
Testament teaching and it's these kind
of things that say hey hold on we do
have it right not because the rabbis
agree but because it lines up with all
of scripture right that the Holy Spirit
speaks the holy spirit's a person the
Holy Spirit gets sent by Jesus and and
the Father the Holy Spirit comes Upon
Jesus and strengthens him and there
there's all these types of things of the
relationship that I think is that I
think is beautiful and in lines up in
scripture perfectly yeah okay so um I
have a question from that does the Old
Testament also talk about the Holy
Spirit sure yes oh yes definitely it
does yeah the Holy Spirit a lot of
places right I know you're about to
you're pulling up some stuff right now
I'm gonna get it bro yeah we gonna do it
yeah he's he'll hook it up and the holy
spirit is active all throughout um all
throughout the Old Testament and so is
the son the son the Father the all this
all of this language that you see in the
New Testament is also used in the Old
Testament so check check out this
interesting thing right so the psalmist
is talking about the Lord right even
before there's a word on my tongue oh
Lord you know it now remember we don't
believe Jesus Is God and the Holy Spirit
is God just because they're called God
or Theos or Elohim right we don't
believe that we believe that Jesus is
God the uncreated creator of the
universe because of their attributes the
things that they do the reason why we
believe that the holy spirit is God is
because it has the attributes of God
right so check this out he's talking to
this is divine name y he's talking about
the knowledge that he has right and
what's one of God's attributes he's
everywhere at once right everywhere at
once look at what the psalmist goes on
to say where can I go from your spirit
or where can I flee from your presence
if I Ascend to Heaven you are there if I
make my bed in shol behold you're there
if I take the wings of dawn if I dwell
in the remotest part of the sea so
basically the spirit of God is
everywhere now that shows that the Holy
Spirit has the attributes of God but now
let's show that the holy spirit is
distinguished from the father and the
son in the Old Testament we're going to
go to Isaiah
48:16 yes but before we go there right
look at who's talking right listen to me
oh Jacob even Israel whom I called I am
he I'm the first and I'm the
last the first and the last who's the
first and the last Jesus
Christ amen amen but before it gets
known as Jesus Christ where're it's the
god of Israel
right right he's the first this is who's
talk he's talking listen to me he's
talking I'm the first I'm the last
surely my hand founded the Earth who
made the Earth right of course Jesus
Colossians 1:15 formed all things right
okay but this is before we know him as
Jesus this is the god of Israel speaking
I made everything right assemble all of
you listen who among them has declared
these things the lord loves him he'll
carry out his good pleasure on Babylon
this is about the Exile who's talking
the god of Israel is talking and look at
what the god of Israel says I even I
have spoken indeed I've called him I've
brought him and he will make his way
successful look what he says come near
to me this who's talking the god of
Israel listen to this from the first
I've not spok spoken in secret from the
time it took place I was there and now
the Lord God this is divine name so y
speaking and he says y has sent me and Y
Spirit father son and spirit in the old
C let me read and now the Lord God has
sent me and his Spirit from the first I
have not spoken in secret from the time
it was there and and now the Lord God
has sent me and his spirit so yeah it
does talk about
God and Jesus Christ and his Spirit
separate and that's the Old Testament
sis that's the Old
Testament you have God who's saying that
God sent him and his Spirit yeah and and
what's even crazy every it's it's
literally saying yud V is speaking not
just God and Elohim generically Y is
speaking and it's saying y v sent me who
is y with the spirit of Y yeah that's
the power of the thing right because
there was only one y yes yes exactly
what does I sorry I haven't heard that
word before yes so in Exodus in Exodus
three yes when the angel of the Bush
when the angel of the Lord appears in
the bush that's burning on fire right
this is Moses at the Mountain of God and
remember this is another amazing clue in
scripture the angel of the Lord
is in the bush the angel of the Lord
never leaves but the god of Abraham
Isaac and Jacob is in the bush who's the
angel of the Lord this is the god of
Abraham Isaac and Jacob I mean is clear
in English I mean you could just read
Exodus 3 it's so clear but when we say
yav he's got when he asks God says to
Moses you know Moses saying what's
what's the name of the person that I
should say send me this is the Hebrew a
so basically his name is
this basically means I am do you know
Arabic um I no I just know how to read
and write I don't
really yes so the semetic language is
share this quality right the form of
being so God is essentially saying the
verb that I am right I am we don't refer
to God as I am I know there are
Christian songs that do that but it's a
little bit of a grammatical problem when
you try to say that the Great I Am you
should be really saying the great he is
and that's really what Y is this is what
people refer to as Yahweh or yahovah or
Jehovah or Yahweh there different ways
people try to pronounce it but that's
the name of God based on the form of
being and eternal existence and that
lines up with what we see in John
chapter one right about the word that
becomes flesh right in the beginning was
the word the word was with God the Word
was God he was in the beginning with God
there was never a point of time that the
word of God was not in existence the
word of God takes on flesh this is Jesus
of Nazareth the Eternal uncreated
creator of the universe who dwells with
humanity and dies for us and is risen
again and by whom we have reconciliation
to God now specifically uh Rabbi so when
she asks like she's never heard of yod
Bob before like specifically can you
tell her what that is because yeah it's
the verbal form but yeah go ahead it's a
yeah it's a verb form so the for so
Hebrew has uh three different forms so
When God Says When God says what his
name is he says which means I am or I
will be Y is the Hebrew way of saying he
will
be right so that's what y v is in Hebrew
it's the four letters of God's Divine
name there it is okay right okay yeah I
this is the first time I learned because
I knew the word
y but I didn't know the four separate
yeah so so the reason why B basically
like so CU yah has like the vowels in
between them right it's it's how you
spell the name it's y a there's a vow
there um you know h e but you know those
A and E they're not originally there you
know that's just the yhw that or in
Hebrew yod he B he you know so so you
know I'm sorry if I'm asking too many
questions you're not don't you can ask
as many as you want they're genuine
you're Lear please do not yeah so I had
another question um so uh I remember
that angel J uh Gabriel or jabriel what
do you say his name g his name's Gabriel
but we know Gabriel um
yeah yeah Angel Gabriel he he he brought
the news of Jesus Christ coming to uh
Mary and the name for Jesus Christ right
um which I know in English is
Emmanuel right and God With Us meaning
the definition of that name but could
you tell me what was the Hebrew word for
Emanuel yes so little a little bit of a
mixup with some of those things but but
it's all good because all the ideas are
right so Emmanuel is what it's talked
about in the prophets that he'll be
called Emmanuel meaning that he'll be
known as God With Us immanu with us L
that he's God with us but the name of
Jesus yesus in Greek is the same thing
as Joshua okay okay when we come so when
we say Jesus that really comes from um
the Hebrew Aramaic form of Yeshua and
that really means that yah saves or the
salvation of yah which is the beginning
of God's name so salvation has come to
God's people through the person of the
Incarnation the sun taking on flesh
so really his so when we think about
names you know we don't have the same
thing in the modern world the name is
just something that's cute right people
just get names because they like them
but in the ancient world they had
meaning they had significance and so the
idea and when you go back to Isaiah the
idea is that God is going to do
something miraculous that it's going to
be a sign that the whole house of
David's going to see and basically this
one that's going to be born of a virgin
is going to be God with us and this is
something only God can do
okay okay I got you thank you um also
could you uh talk a bit more about the
um the red heer topic because I recently
uh learned about the finding of the four
right heer uh five but now four I guess
and uh and how the preparation is
happening for the next month because
like I know that this is the month of
Ramadan for Muslims right they're
fasting and also it was pretty um
strange to me because uh one of my
friends she's ethopian Christian and she
started fasting the very first day of
Ramadan as well so they they fast for
like 50 something days um because they
missed the Saturdays um and and um they
have the Passover coming and I know that
in April 8 there is this whole um solar
eclipse coming up so it's a lot of
things happening right could you like go
into details about like the preparation
for that what should we do as people I
know I have yeah I have I have advice
for you and and for the whole body
Messiah but it's not really um advice
that's specific about what you're saying
about the red heer so basically the red
heer the ashes it got burned it was part
of the offering had to do with being
mixed with water for um cleansing and
purification all these type of purpose
in the levitical system so the Jewish
people there's something called the
Temple Institute they want to rebuild
the Temple in Jerusalem well you can't
because you know the alasas and stuff is
on top of it so you really can't do
that something I want you to think about
just as a little bit of a nugget we
inherit from Judaism the idea of a third
Temple so a lot of Christians look for
the Third Temple Third Temple Third
Temple based upon the ending of The Book
of
Ezekiel right but if we take into
account the New Covenant we have the
notion of the Antichrist going into the
temple that's rebuilt in the future and
desecrating and claiming himself to be
God right right and that Temple is going
to be desecrated then we have the Temple
of the Messiah so I don't think it's
inaccurate to say that there could be
four temples really right the Temple of
the Antichrist is going to go into and
then the Temple of the Messiah so that's
essentially what it does but my advice
for Christians and Believers all over
the place is to not be so um concerned
with the future events fol on how you
live your life today and be more focused
on looking at the past to see what we
can learn from it because even when
Jesus was going to the Cross look what
he tells his disciples I gotta go to
Jerusalem I Gotta Die right I gotta go
they said no Lord may it never be hold
on these are Hebrew speakers they know
Greek they knew Aramaic they're living
in the first century they're walking
with Jesus for years and they could not
comprehend that he had to go to the
Cross they didn't know the times and
Seasons that they were in so I think for
there has to be some humility about the
future and I think that sometimes it's
more of a distraction I think we can
focus fully on living holy today um with
all the things that we know of scripture
and what occurred in the past and let
the future take let tomorrow take care
of tomorrow okay thank you so much
absolutely you know well with that with
that being said do you have any other
questions do you want maybe some
clarification on maybe some things that
were said uh you're all good right thank
you so much yeah I'll be praying for my
family and uh all of you as well um hope
you have a nice rest of your day all
right you're welcome anytime sis if you
like let's say your mom comes up because
there's going to be more objections and
we can you can come here and we'll show
you how to deal with them okay
thank okay take care of yourself God
bless
you